[موسيقى]
115 شخصًا، 22 مليون دولار أمريكي، وهو في
المتوسط ​​عدد الأشخاص الذين
لقوا حتفهم ومبلغ الأموال المفقودة كل
يوم بسبب الأحداث المناخية القاسية في جميع
أنحاء العالم في الخمسين عامًا الماضية،
السبب البشري، الاحتباس الحراري يعيد تشكيل
عالمنا، الأنهار الجليدية  ذوبان مستويات سطح البحر،
والعواصف
المتزايدة، والحرارة الشديدة، والانخفاض الشديد،
والناس في كل مكان يعانون، لكن من
يتأثر أكثر
خبراء المناخ يقولون إن موقعك،
وثروتك، وعرقك، وحتى مستوى
تعليمك يمكن أن يؤثر على تجربتك
مع تغير المناخ، لكنه فعل ذلك  أنت تعلم أن
جنسك يلعب أيضًا دورًا كبيرًا، إليك
أربعة أمثلة على كيفية تأثر النساء والفتيات
الأكثر
تأثراً عندما يفشل محصول الأسرة أو
لا يوجد المزيد من الأسماك في المصيد.
تزيد التوترات في الأسرة مما
قد يؤدي إلى العنف. تظهر البيانات الواردة من كينيا
ذلك  كان لدى النساء اللاتي يعشن في أجزاء من
البلاد التي شهدت أحداث مناخية قاسية
فرصة أكبر بنسبة 60٪
للإبلاغ عن عنف الشريك الحميم.
في دراسة أخرى من الهند وباكستان
ونيبال، ارتبط ارتفاع درجات الحرارة بمقدار درجة مئوية واحدة
أيضًا بزيادة العنف
ضد النساء والنساء و  الفتيات اللاتي
يضطررن إلى مغادرة منازلهن بسبب
تغير المناخ هن أيضًا أكثر عرضة
لخطر العنف، بينما الاستحمام أثناء النوم
أو ارتداء الملابس في
خيام أو مخيمات ملاجئ الطوارئ فإن خطر
العنف الجنسي هو حقيقة مأساوية في
حياتهن كمهاجرات أو
لاجئات.  يشكلن ما يقرب من 4% من
العمال الزراعيين في جميع أنحاء العالم في
أفريقيا جنوب الصحراء الكبرى، ويصل هذا العدد إلى
50%، ومع ذلك فإن أقل من 133% في المتوسط ​​من
مالكي الأراضي في العالم هم من النساء. وهذا
مهم لأن ملكية الأراضي هي
مصدر للثروة والمكانة ويمكن أن
تكون  تخفف من آثار المناخ
علاوة على ذلك، تم وصف النساء على أنهن
مضيفات رائعات للأرض
يمكن أن تساعد معرفتهن الواسعة في حماية
التكيف وبناء القدرة على التكيف مع
تغير المناخ إذا تم منحهن الفرصة فقط
لقضاء النساء ثلاثة أضعاف
ساعات العمل غير مدفوعة الأجر في أعمال الرعاية  الرجال
يقضون 4 ساعات و25 دقيقة كل
يوم، وتغير المناخ الذي أدى إلى تفاقم
الطقس القاسي يؤدي إلى تفاقم هذا التفاوت،
وفقًا لإحدى الدراسات، فعندما تتعرض
للحرارة الشديدة، ستعمل النساء في الولايات المتحدة
يومًا إضافيًا شهريًا، لكن في الهند
ستعمل 90 دقيقة إضافية كل يوم.  وما يصل
إلى 150 دقيقة إضافية يوميًا في
نيجيريا، يكون لذلك تأثيرًا كبيرًا
حيث أن النساء والفتيات لديهن
وقت أقل في حياتهن التعليمية
وأخيرًا، هل تعلم أن الحرارة الشديدة
يمكن أن تؤثر على قدرة المرأة الحامل على
تنظيم درجة حرارة جسمها وأن ذلك
شديد  يمكن أن يؤدي التعرض لدرجات الحرارة المرتفعة إلى
زيادة خطر ولادة جنين ميت والولادة
المبكرة،
وهذا ليس كل ما في تلوث الهواء
الذي يأتي معظمه من حرق الوقود
الأحفوري، كما تم ربطه أيضًا بمواليد جنين ميتين، فقد
قدرت دراسة أجريت عام 2022 أن
ما يقرب من 40% من ولادات ميتات في العالم
يمكن أن تؤدي إلى ولادة أطفال ميتين.  تكون مرتبطة بالتعرض
لجزيئات التلوث، تغير المناخ مشكلة من صنع الإنسان
وتتطلب حلاً نسويًا.
الآن، لم تعد النساء والفتيات مجرد ضحايا
لتغير المناخ، بل إن نساء السكان الأصليين
في طليعة
الحفاظ على البيئة، والعديد من النساء المزارعات لديهن
معرفة تقليدية
بالطرق المستدامة و  لقد قادت النساء والفتيات منذ فترة طويلة
النشاط المناخي، ألا يمكننا أن
نثق بأولئك الذين
بنوا علاقة مستدامة
مع الطبيعة لفترة طويلة، يجب أن تقود النساء
ويجب أن نضعهم على طاولة صنع القرار